moment d'émotion cet avant-midi dans le
vieux longueuil alors qu'on dévoiler une
plaque commémorative en mémoire d'un
jeune nick dalcourt jacques ça fait très
exactement un an que la jeune femme a
été battue à mort et il ya du nouveau
dans cette enquête
c'est assez curieux parce que depuis un
an il n'y avait presque rien en fait on
est de attendre un an à voir comment
c'est d'avoir du nouveau
bien sûr il ya eu cette arrestation s'en
souviendra quelques jours après le
meurtre d'un suspect d'un homme les
policiers les ont arrêtés lors détenu
pendant 48 heures et l'ont relâché parce
qu'il avait pas suffisamment de preuves
semble-t-il bien là curieusement ce
premier anniversaire du meurtre donc
deux sonic d'alco la police nous annonce
que tout le dossier de summer vient
d'être confiée à nouveau pour une autre
fois aux avocats du ministère la justice
donc ce que l'on doit comprendre s'il ya
du nouveau manifestement où il ya un
complément preuve manifestement sinon on
ne le ferait pas donc tout le dossier
est entre les mains du dpcp comme le
confirme la police de longueuil
le dpcp analysera tous les dossiers et
par la suite
une décision sera rendue je ne peux pas
me prononcer s'il ya eu des éléments
nouveaux ou pas cette fait partie des
éléments dans kite et c'est des choses
qui seront révélés à la cour voilà je le
disais un cérémonie ce matin ouais
beaucoup d'émotion évidemment c'est
organisé par la ville de longueuil on a
une gueule une place sur la place sur la
piste cyclable à ou lieu le meurtre
liana alors les proches de la victime
étaient là les parents le père la mère
et le marron le cfaa très s'imaginer on
peut imaginer ça à perdre sa fille de 23
ans dans des circonstances pareilles
c'est plutôt difficile on a pu
rencontrer la mère de jeunes et que
d'harcourt maintenant d'un
un procès sans fin si les enfants qui
étaient avec intérêt les pannes à chaque
heure c'est inacceptable c'est c'est
aigle inacceptable cette serait toujours
la douleur est toujours aussi présent
oui parce qu'elle faisait sa petite
chicane alors ce soit à patrice en
terminant il ya une vigile organisé donc
par la famille de janick valco sur la
piste ita du vieux-longueuil là où a eu
lieu le meurtre
merci jacques vous en prie à voir